the average viewer watching mainstream
news would think the latest violence
between Israelis and Palestinians began
with the kidnapping of three Israeli
teens on June 12th guess what that's not
the case here's what the mainstream
media isn't telling you before the
Israeli teenagers were kidnapped and
killed five Palestinian children had
been killed by Israel in 2014 alone
their deaths didn't generate
international outrage or a global
campaign but what they did do was add to
Palestinians ever-growing frustration
with the Israeli occupation today
Israeli warplanes hit more than 100
targets in Gaza responding to rockets
that were launched into Israel by
Islamic militants the mainstream media
does a really good job in making this
seem like a war between two equal sides
it's not we're basically looking at
asymmetric warfare between Israel's
mighty western-backed military versus
Palestinian fighters equipped with
mainly homemade rockets in the deceives
Gaza Strip the massive airstrikes Israel
is launching at Gaza now have killed
dozens destroying entire homes attacks
from Gaza into Israel don't compare just
look at the numbers since 2009 Israeli
forces have killed more than 600
Palestinians in Gaza and the occupied
West Bank the number of Israelis killed
by Palestinians during that time just
over 40 and unlike Israel Gaza has no
sirens to warn of imminent strikes no
bomb shelters and no Iron Dome missile
defense system to intercept Israel's
attacks the hospitals in Gaza can barely
deal with the influx of patients coming
in now Israeli spokesmen are all over
the media saying their goal is to hurt
Hamas and end its attacks but very few
outlets actually report Hamas is
objectives even though it announced them
many times
Hamas is asking for Israel to end its
raids in the West Bank to release all
the prisoners who were re-arrested after
being freed in a previous prisoner swap
and to lift the siege on Gaza so Israel
wants to stop Hamas that hasn't happened
yet even though this isn't their first
military assault in the past there's
been operation summer rains operation
hot winter Operation Cast Lead operation
returning echo and operations Hiller of
Defense Justin
whew you think they get the hint bombing
Gaza doesn't work maybe it's time
instead to lift the siege on Gaza and
end the collective punishment there but
you probably won't hear that in the
media
[Music]